fun dynamic Oh have announced that
tekken 7 won't be arriving quite as
early as they first suggested originally
slated to arrive in early 2017 the
publisher have now revealed that the 3d
fighting game is going to hit shelves on
jun 2 of this year project leader
katsuhiro harada told GameSpot we were
trying our best to get the game out at
that time to get it into the hands of
users as early as possible we saw some
titles some from our own company and
some from others which didn't have a
very good launch because of a lack of
content or whatever it was that caused
players to bash the product funday Namco
came to the conclusion that it was
better to delay the game than risk
releasing an inferior product porada
added that they are aware the game's new
release date isn't meeting the original
promise to launch early this year but
that they made some hard decisions and
that was the result for more on tekken 7
and all the other things that matter in
video games check back to GameSpot's